>>> NEW YORKEWLY ELECTED
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS GEORGE
SANTOS IS FACING SERIOUS
QUESTIONS OVER WHAT HE TOLD
VOTERS ABOUT HIS LIFE STORY.
FOLLOWING A PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
INVESTIGATION BY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
THE BIO THAT HE PRESENTED AT
VARIOUS POINTS DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN JUST NOT REALLY SEEMING
TO ADD UP.
AND INCLUDING HIS EDUCATIONAL
BACKGROUND, HIS EMPLOYMENT
HISTORY, EVEN A CHARITY THAT HE
SAID HE FOUNDED.
LET'S TICK THROUGH JUST SOME OF
THIS.
SANTOS HAS SAID THAT HE RECEIVED
DEGREESES FROM BARUCH ANDP NYU,
CNN HAS REACHED OUT AND NEITHER
SCHOOL COULD FIND RECORDS OF
THAT.
HIS CAMPAIGN BIO ALSO MENTIONED
WORKING AT BOTH CITIGROUP AND
GOLDMAN SACHS.
NEITHER FIRM HAS RECORD OF THAT
AND HE CLAIMED THAT HE FOUNDED A
NONPROFIT ANIMAL RESCUE CALLED
FRIENDS OF PET UNITED BUT THE
OPERATION IS NOT FOUND IN THE
IRS SEARCHABLE DATA BASE AND
THAT IS JUST SOME OF IT.
JOINING ME NOW IS GRACE ACHFORD
WITH "THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHO
BROKE THE STORY.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT GOT YOU ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS BACKGROUND,
THAT KIND OF LED YOU DOWN THIS
PATH?
>> HI, KATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
THIS ALL STARTED SHORTLY AFTER
THE ELECTION.
MY COLLEAGUE MICHAEL GOLD AND I
WERE ASSIGNED TO WRITE WHAT WE
THOUGHT WOULD BE A QUICK PIECE
ON THIS NEW CONGRESSMAN FROM
LONG ISLAND WHO IS DRAWING A LOT
OF ATTENTION.
HE FLIPPED WHAT HAD BEEN A BLUE
DISTRICT RED BUT HE WAS ALSO
SORT OF THIS NEW MODEL OF
PERHAPS WHAT THE GOP COULD BE IN
THE FUTURE.
HE'S ONLY 34 YEARS OLD, HE'S
LATINO AND HE'S GAY.
WHICH WAS ALL VERY, VERY
INTERESTING.
AND SO AS WE STARTED TO LOOK
INTO HIM, HE LOOKED AT HIS BIO
AND WE LOOKED AT ALL SORTS OF
DINK THINGS.
THE PET CHARITY THAT YOU MENGED
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CAUGHT
ME EYE BECAUSE I'VE DIDN'T SOME
REPORTING INTO SOME NONPROFITS
IN THE PAST AND SO ONE OF FIS
THINGS I DID WAS LOOK FOR SOME
OF THE FILINGS BECAUSE HE WAS
VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT BEING TY
501-C 3 AND WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
FIND THAT WITH THE IRS.
WE HAD SOME BIGGER QUESTIONS.
>> AND I WANT TO READ AND I KNOW
YOU'VE SEEN THIS STATEMENT, BUT
I DO WANT TO READ WHAT AN
ATTORNEY FOR SANTOS HAS TOLD CNN
IN A STATEMENT.
THAT THE TIMES, WAS ATTEMPTED TO
SMEAR THE CONGRESSMAN ELECT WITH
DEFAMATORY ALLEGATIONS AND
SAYING THAT SANTOS REPRESENTS
THE KIND OF PROGRESS THAT THE
LEFT IS SO THREATENED BY, A GAY
LATINO MIGRANT AND REPUBLICAN
WHO WON A BIDEN DISTRICT IN
OVERWHELMING FASHION BY SHOWING
EVERY DAY VOTERS THERE IS A
BETTER OPTION THAN THE BROKEN
PROMISES AND FAILED POLICIES OF
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BUT I DO NOT SEE THEM DISPUTING
ANY OF YOUR REPORTING OR NOT
PROVIDING ANY OF WHAT WOULD BE
PRETTY EASY DETAILS TO CLARIFY
THIS, RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME GOING
BACK AND FORTH WITH MR. SANTOS'
LAWYER AND TRYING HARD TO JUST
CLEAR UP WHAT WE THOUGHT WERE
SOME INCONSISTENCIES IN HIS BIO
AND ONE OF THE EASY THINGS YOU
DO IS SORT OF CALL AROUND AND
TALK TO PEOPLE WHO WORKED AT A
PLACE AT THE SAME TIME SO YOU
COULD GET A SENSE OF THEM AND
WHAT KIND OF COLLEAGUE THEY WERE
AND EMPLOYEE.
BUT DIDN'T HAVE THOSE KIND OF
THINGS.
SO WE WERE JUST ASKING FOR THAT
KIND OF -- THOSE TYPES OF
DOCUMENTS AND DETAILS AND EVEN
DATES WHEN HE WAS AT A PLACE AND
WHEN THEY COULDN'T REPEATEDLY
THEY COULDN'T PROVIDE THAT TO
US, WHICH WAS VERY DISAPPOINTING
FOR US.
>> YEAH.
SO ROBERT ZIMMERMAN IS THE
DEMOCRAT WHO LOST TO SANTOS
IN -- TO SANTOS IN THIS
CONGRESSIONAL RACE.
HE WAS ON CNN THIS MORNING AND
HE HE SAID THAT HIS CAMPAIGN WAS
AWARE, HE SAID THAT THE DCC WAS
AWARE THERE WAS QUESTIONS ABOUT
HIS RESUME AND THERE WAS SOME
LOCAL REPORTING BUT IT BUT NOT
TO THE EXTENT OF WHAT YOU HAVE
UNCOVER AND WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
REPORTING ON.
AND ZIMMERMAN NOW SAID THAT --
HAS -- I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU
HIS TAKE ON WHERE THE FOCUS HE
THINKS SHOULD BE NOW.
LET ME PLAY THIS.
>> THE ONLY FINGER POINTING
SHOULD BE AT GEORGE SANTOS.
THIS MAN IS A FRAUDSTER.
THE ALLEGATIONS OF FRAUD AND
CORRUPTION ARE WELL DOCUMENTED
IN THE TIMES STORY AND THERE HAS
BE A HOUSE ETHIC INVESTIGATION
AND A DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION.
>> FROM YOUR REPORTING, DO YOU
GET THE SENSE THAT HIS CAMPAIGN
AND THE DCCC THAT ME MISSED
SOMETHING HERE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE WERE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE SEVERAL WEEKS TO
LOOK INTO THIS AND PART OF IT
WAS AS I SAID, ONCE WE STARTED
TURNING UP THINGS, MORE AND MORE
THINGS WE STARTED TO CHECK
DIDN'T ADD UP AS YOU SAID IN
YOUR INTRODUCTION AND THEN WE
JUST FOCUSED ON THE DOCUMENTS.
WE LOOKED AT HIS FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURE AND KIND OF -- I
THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
QUESTIONS THAT OUR REPORTING
RAISED WAS THE SOURCE OF MR.
SANTOS'S FORTUNE IS.
HE LOANED OVER $700,000 TO HIS
CAMPAIGN WHICH IS NO SMALL SUM.
AND WAS NOT -- DIDN'T DISCLOSE
SORT OF ANY OF THE CLIENTS THAT
PERHAPS COULD HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO THAT OR ANSWER SOME OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT WE SHARED
WITH HIM.
AND, YEAH, I THINK THAT THERE IS
A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT -- THAT
WE NEED HIM TO ANSWER.
>> AND YOU GET AT SOMETHING
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS NOT JUST A WILD STORY
ABOUT SOMEONE JUICING UP THEIR
BIO.
THERE IS POTENTIAL OF ETHICAL
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR
SOMEONE WHO FILES FALSE
DISCLOSURES TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT
DEMOCRATS AND/OR REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO DO ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT IS A
MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION.
YOU KNOW, DID THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN SORT OF A TIGHT SPOT
HERE.
KEVIN McCARTHY IN PARTICULAR.
HE'S REALLY STRUGGLING AND
TRYING VERY HARD TO MAINTAIN
CONTROL OF HIS CONFERENCE AND
GEORGE SANTOS IS ONE OF THINGS
THAT HE DID SAY ON TWITTER WHEN
HE WAS NOT RESPONDING TO OUR
QUESTIONS WAS THAT HE PLEDGED
HIS SUPPORT FOR MR. McCARTHY.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, IN THEORY,
THERE COULD BE A CALL FOR HIS
RESIGNATION BUT IT IS DIFFICULT
TO SEE YOU KNOW, HOW THAT WILL
HAPPEN, PERHAPS.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO CALLING FOR
INVESTIGATIONS.
OBVIOUSLY FALSIFYING YOUR BIO,
IF IN FACT THAT IS WHAT COULD BE
PROVEN, IT COULD BE AN ETHICAL
VIOLATION.
SOME OF THE CRIMINAL CHARGES
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DIG UP IN
BRAZIL ALSO POTENTIALLY, BUT
YES, I THINK AS YOU SAID, THE
CAMPAIGN DISCLOSURE ARE PROBABLY
THE KEY THING.
IF IN FACT IT IS PROVED THAT HE
WILLFULLY AND IN FULL KNOWLEDGE
ADMITTED DETAILS, THAT COULD BE
A CRIMINAL MATTER.
>> AND LOTS OF QUESTIONS AS
YOU'VE LAID OUT.
WE INVITED GEORGE SANTOS ON TO
THE PROFWAGRAM TO TAKE SOME OF
QUESTIONS AND HIS TEAM HAS NOT
YET GIVEN US AN ANSWER.
WE DO WANT TO SAY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR REPORTING.